Olivia Pratt corbell's Funeral took
place at a church just meters from where
she went to school
her small coffin
watched by heartbroken family
and Friends
and hundreds of people who didn't know
Olivia but who feel her loss
and who as her family asked wore her
favorite color
they passed my house and as I passed me
off my heart just like sank like this is
new Fiona felt before but he shouldn't
maybe see a coffin that small really
Olivia was in the same year as a little
grandson Oscar
just lovely little girl with a waste of
a life so
this has been a private service for
Olivia's family and her friends but many
members of the general public have also
come here to listen to the service
that's being broadcast on outside
speakers but mainly just to be here to
pay their respects to this nine-year-old
girl and her family and that's how they
heard the bravest of eulogies delivered
by Olivia's mum Lev taught so many
people's hearts and was lost in the door
by everyone
she will never be forgotten
so Wars and I will never say goodbye but
what I will say
is good night love you see you in the
morning
Olivia was standing behind her mum when
she was shot in the chest
the gunman had chased another man into
their home and opened fire
police have arrested nine people but has
yet charged no one for the murder of
this innocent child so tragically killed
so deeply mourned
[Music]
Catherine evertotsi Sky News Liverpool